alors que le monde s'est lancé dans une
course folle pour la vaccination contre
la copie 19
voilà qu'un des vaccins autorisés est au
coeur d'une importante polémique
pourrait être retiré du marché un vaccin
astrazeneca soulève régulièrement des
craintes ce vaccin celle astrazeneca
extrait du laboratoire anglo-suédois du
même nom fait partie des trois vaccins
au monde à avoir reçu le feu vert des
autorités pour être administré avec le
célèbre pfizer et le modern art si de
nombreux patients dans le monde ont
témoigné des effets secondaires
particulièrement violent du vaccin
astrazeneca
aujourd'hui c'est la mort d'une
infirmière de 49 ans des suites de sa
vaccination qui inquiète dans certains
cas le vaccin pourrait créer la
formation de caillots sanguins pouvant
causer la mort suite à ce décès
l'estonie la lituanie la lettonie le
luxembourg ont décidé de suspendre les
vaccinations de doses issus de ce lot de
vaccins danemark qui décide brutalement
de suspendre son utilisation avait dans
la foulée
l'islande est maintenant la norvège il y
à quelques heures olivier derand annoncé
que la vaccination avec astrazeneca se
poursuivraient en france sur 5 millions
d'européens
trente personnes ont présenté des
troubles de la coagulation
alors faut-il faire interdire le vaccin
astrazeneca
merci martin blachier d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup merci fabrice division
vous êtes des habitués du plateau et là
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on peut se
poser beaucoup de questions sur ce
vaccin
astrazeneca est ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter martin blachier moi je suis
pas inquiet pour l'instant et je voulais
corriger quelque chose que des
documentaires aux élites qui est morte
des suites de la vaccination astrazeneca
moi je dis elle est mort après l'action
et machines astrazeneca ça veut pas dire
que c'est lié au fait qu'ils avaient
encore vacciner des gens qui sont des
thromboses y en a des milliers chaque
jour parfois ça va arriver après une
vaccination astrazeneca pour l'instant
il ya personne qui a établi un lien
clair entre la vaccination et des
thromboses qui ont été décrites d'accord
donc c'est cette formation de caillots
sanguins pour l'instant on n'a aucune
preuve que ce soit à cause du vaccin
exactement et d'ailleurs même l' agence
danoise le dit simplement les mettre en
pause parce qu'il secours
ils savent que ils ont arrêté donc au
danemark en norvège en islande pourquoi
il décide d'arrêter parce qu'il ya moins
de redouter dès qu'il ya un tout petit
doute comme c'est tellement grave est
que sur le plan juridique et politique
c'est extrêmement risquée du coup ils
attendent mais vous verrez que très
bientôt il va reprendre d'accord alors
fabrice di vizio est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec martin blachier en fait à
[Rires]
part bien monsieur blachier jim martin
dim
en l'absence de preuves c'est ça vient
de causalité vous souvenez pas d'une
histoire qui s'appelle le sang contaminé
monsieur blachier me souvenais pas de
l'arrêt du conseil d'état soit sang
contaminé vous souvenez pas de l'arrêt
de la cour de justice de l'union
européenne sur l'hépatite b et vous
souvenez pas qu'on a un principe qui est
le principe de précaution qui est
clairement inscrit dans la constitution
et qui fait qu' on n'a pas besoin
d'attendre la preuve et rappelez vous
que dans la sphère qui nous concerne
c'est à dire celle du co vide c'est
précisément ce qui nous a mis dedans
c'est à dire que mois de février quand
je disais attention on sait pas ce que
c'est et arrêtez de comparer à la grippe
tout le monde disait oui nous on n'a pas
de preuve que ce soit grave et je disais
fait gaffe les mecs parce que
concrètement le principe de précaution
il consiste en cas d'incertitudes
qu'est ce que je fais c'est ça la vraie
question et voilà vous êtes gonflés de
parler de ça vous dit exactement le
contraire
à chaque fois que vous parlez
de confinement si vous dites c'est quoi
cette précaution n'a pas la preuve que
le congo se protège donc on doit pas
faire cas maintenant vous retourner
servir
j'étais là cette affaire attendez vous
savez qu'il y avait une culture de santé
publique il est là le problème c'est que
la notion principe de précaution nous
est complètement étrangère parce que
précisément le principe de précaution il
est qu'est-ce que je fais quand je ne
suis pas sûr
or dans le confinement nous avons des
études qui vous disent effectivement que
ça marche des vidéos on n'est jamais sûr
à 100% de rien c'est rien dans la ville
c'est là mais n'existe pas zéro n'est
pas là monsieur blachier le problème il
est exactement ce que vous a répondu la
cour de justice de l'union va vous
l'avez la matinée dans la sphère de
l'hépatite b g l'arrêt sous les yeux et
excusez moi je fais partie des gens
quand même qu'ils sont un peu des
spécialistes du principe un on est peu
nombreux en finir avec wayne je vous
avez travaillé à quoi la santé publique
ça fait un petit peu partie de mon
domaine d'activité et qu'est ce que vous
dit la cour
en l'absence de consensus le consensus
scientifique le défaut d'un vaccin et le
lien de causalité entre celui-ci et une
maladie peuvent être prouvées par un
faisceau d'indicés
ce qui met pas le cash qui met pas le
coeur à dire que ce n'est pas le cas
alors que vous avez croire que tout les
agents les mêmes la vaillance danoise
d'ixelles cour familiale attend de voir
pour l'instant martin maître la palombe
chose en pose le problème prévoit d'en
venir à mener c'est notamment l'arrêt
sur le sang contaminé
qu'est ce que vous dit l'arrêt du tout à
la hauteur mais me dites pas que ça
aucun rappeur de la salle quel était le
problème dans le sang contaminé
c'est qu'on a voulu attendre de savoir
si réellement le chauffage du sens et
est nécessaire on attendre est bon mais
qu elle alors qu'elle appartenait à
l'autorité administrative informée de
façon non équivoque de l'existence d'un
risque de contamination des transfusés
et la possibilité d'y parer par
l'utilisation des produits chauffés qui
étaient alors disponibles sur le marché
d'interdire sans attendre laissez moi
finir d'avoir la certitude rien dire que
[Rires]
d'attendre sa écouter écouter
d'interdire ce sans attendre d'avoir la
certitude que tous les lots de produits
dérivés du sang étaient contaminés que
cette carence volume est de nature à
engager la responsabilité visio la suite
je suis d'accord sur le fond mais ce qui
est hallucinant c'est que même quand
vous avez raison vous dites n'importe
quoi vous n'avez pas de documents sur le
confinement alors vous allez nous
ressortir mon vieux trucs sur le
confinement n'est pas utile
comme vous avez des vieux et foncé et
donc vous prenez le sont contaminés avec
un vague harek vous avez retrouvé
vous ne pouvez jamais avoir les bons
documents et feront ce sujet j'aimais
d'accord avec vous mais comme vous dites
n'importe quoi et bien c'est un nom une
autre fois j'ai parlé effectivement du
malade imaginaire devant thomas mais
parfois russe pour la fois russe vous
dire un truc qui me vient à l ac c'est
un livre de gravillons j'irai cracher
sur vos tombes ah ouais ouais parce que
finalement vous fait qu'elle ait envie
de cracher sur ta gueule non scellées ce
qui fait là ce qui crachent sur les
tombes des morts
raté après ça ou rien plus vite compte
sur plus de dix ans on a sauvé des
dizaines de vies en angleterre grâce aux
vaccins vous le banner vaccin est
dangereux c'est pas moi qui le dis vous
êtes trop pays qu'ils ont suspendu passé
quand même se dire je veux bien qu'à un
moment donné si vous voulez on passe son
temps à se référer alter1fo année là
mais je comprends que vous avez de faire
des joutes verbales mais ce que vous
dites c'est très dangereux parce qu'il
ya des gens qui vont croire les ultimes
questions à mes deux parents et évêques
man astrazeneca je le faisais des
risques aux deux parents est bel et bien
sûr j'ai 100 % de conscience avec la
chaîne abc en question ce million britt
janyk vaccinés s'ils rien passé onze
maisons britannique
je vais vous poser une question je fais
rien passé oui aucun effet secondaire et
même pas 30 3% mais c'est pas grave
peu importe mais où tout est simple en
fait alors allez-y sera posée là c'est
ça que dites vous ce soir aux français
vous dites vaccinez vous avec ses astra
zeneca ce vaccin est parfaitement secure
et ne présente aucune espèce de
commencement dérangé il s'appelle le
bénéfice est ce que c'est que le
bénéfice non mais jamais les faits si ça
veut dire que le bénéfice est
immensément plus grand que le réseau
social risque qui n'est même pas encore
prouvé ci serait qu'une personne une
personne de 50 ans serait mort d'une
embolie pulmonaire elle à une embolie
pulmonaire après cette vacciner on sait
même pas si c'est relié à la vaccination
et on sait qu'en écosse et des dix mille
vies qui ont été sauvées grâce avec six
nations a vu la demande de mortalité
chuté drastiquement
alors faites attention côté des jeunes
des médecins refusent de discuter
d'habitude sur les faits du confinement
mais là c'est grave c'est la vaccination
est le seul vaccin qu'on aura si vous
voulez moi ce que je considère monsieur
blachier
c'est que vous êtes présomptueux dans
cette affaire rien d'autre et que
finalement vous prenez des vessies pour
des lanternes et vous présenter les
hypothèses comme des certitudes et c'est
bien ça qui nous bouffe mais alors il a
vacciné ses parents c'est son problème
alors mais il faut arrêter cinq minutes
avant de donner si vous voulez on a
trois pays qui ont suspendu le vaccin
parce qu'ils ont considéré que le
principe de précaution est bien de pays
qui ne l'ont pas de sens
s'il est là combien de pays l'italie
l'espagne le portugal la pologne
le problème se pose pas en ces termes et
combien de patients finalement dans la
sphère du sang contaminé
mais pourquoi à chaque fois que je
prends une référence elle vous pose un
problème c'est l'argent à voir mais
pourquoi ne leur vient d'abord le patch
1 5l tadic ce que vous avez à dire bien
précis du site de précaution a été
dégagée à l'occasion de cette affaire
il est celui qui nous a servi de guide
au fil du temps la vache folle a été
exactement ce qui a caractérisé le
principe de précaution la question elle
est qu'est-ce que je fais quand je n'ai
pas de certitudes et attendez là ce que
vous dites est totalement ridicule parce
que dans ce cas là il va attaquer vous
savez bien que des vaccins de grippe que
derrière ce vaccin de la grippe non il
ya beaucoup plus de morts donc quand
vous parlez effectivement du
bénéfice-risque ya juste à un moment
donné où il faut quand même calculé un
peu les choses
regardez le alors la grippe vous êtes au
courant qu'il ya des vaccins contre la
grippe chaque année et vous êtes au
courant qu'il ya plus de morts
quand vous faites un prorata par rapport
aux kovy del astrazeneca ya plus de
morts de gens vaccinés après la grippe
est furieuse le vaccin sera donnée
défoncé va te défoncer alors moi je vais
vous répondre en deux temps les vaccins
contre la grippe
il existe depuis combien de temps
monsieur et vous savez ce que c'est
qu'une à mêmes conditionnelle et papa ça
répondait non non répond des chiffres
non mais pour multiplier repartir
chiffres et ces questions et répondez
moi
non le problème c'est que la question
des chiffres connus il importe non mais
chaque donneur il part sur un autre
sujet le prévenant la saga sur les
chiffres elle n'a pas de sens de votre
question les choix les chips et quand ça
nous arrange
pourquoi parce que vous comparer des
choux et des carottes alors excusez moi
l'expression est ça ma politique
non parce que la firme sont contaminés
elle se réfère exactement au principe de
précaution on est la jambe gauche et le
vaccin contre la grippe arrête tout le
pays ne l'est pas il raconte des
histoires pas se raconter à vos
interventions entre gitans le jura
s'alarmer je vous avait coûté deux
minutes parce que le bouhris général
télé gens qui sont en train de crever
moi j'ai des gens proches de moi qui
sont en train de mourir du coc vide qui
ont 55 ans aujourd'hui et est depuis
hier sont en réanimation ils vont très
mal vous savez que les services de
réanimation aujourd'hui ils sont saturés
ya plus de 4000 personnes en rit
aujourd'hui ont des programmes les gens
et vous savez très bien que plus il ya
de gens du kobe denrées a plus il ya de
chances d'avoir des morts en règle
générale dans notre pays aujourd'hui il
ya des vaccins il faut que les gens ils
aillent se faire vacciner
mais quand il ya un million six cent
mille personnes à date qui ont été
vaccinées en france le seul moyen que
les gens se fassent vacciner il ya de
moins en moins de failles leurs sur le
marché c'est la strada n'est qu'a donc
vous êtes en train de dire aujourd'hui
aux gens attention à la strada les cas
et les gens ne vont pas aller se faire
vacciner et on n'est encore fait mais
encore aux gens des années mais aussi
économique pour notre pays je réponds à
une personne à la fois vrai et faux
nicolas perdre il avait décidé deux
choses 1 d'être un menteur vous en avez
le droit c'est un endroit qui vous dit
que vous êtes un menteur je dis vous
êtes un menteur parce que finalement
vous dites aux gens il faut se faire
vacciner vous n'avez aucune qualité pour
dire aux gens ce qu'ils doivent faire et
se terminer dès qu'on est terminée il ya
1 13 milliard et moi excusez moi
le principe est la liberté vaccinale
alors excusez moi monsieur le principe
et la liberté vaccinale
les gens peuvent se faire vacciner mais
ne doivent pas se faire vacciner et vous
n'avez aucune qualité pour venir dire à
la place du gouvernement
si les gens doivent se faire vacciner là
où celui ci a dit qu'il pouvait se faire
vacciner et que le principe aujourd'hui
n'est pas la vaccination obligatoire
mais la liberté de vaccination vous
seriez bien le fait que la rhétorique et
du droit mais le fait excuser moi vous
êtes venu ce bateau ya maintenant deux
mois pour nous expliquer qu'on l'oublié
mais rien à faire
nili confinement ni les menaces ni rien
en mettant au mépris de tout ce qu'elle
fait tout les tous les pays du monde
tout le monde fait vacciner israël
devait être gênée elle a réussi à
arrêter messi ne se fait pas avec
séville et donc vous vous êtes en train
de dire aux français on drame on ramasse
que vous attendez ecoutez-moi m donc on
tout le monde rame et demi comme jamais
dans le monde entier et vous m'expliquer
à la télévision française qui vous
passent à vacciner je vous jure que ces
jeux vous dire que c'est inaudible je
vous jure c'est pas possible d'entendre
ça non c'est pas possible vos rangs des
gros yeux messieurs si vous me plaît car
il voulait rester s'il vous plaît
d'interpréter ce que je dis par ailleurs
à l'écouté parce que soit vous n'écoutez
rien soit vous ne comprenez rien à ça un
peu sais pas mais le fait est là c'est
vraiment ça nos choix n'est pas dû au
jeu
ne faut pas se faire des leçons ce n'est
pas l'objet du débat jeudi pour par
contre effectivement je sais que je dis
c'est qu'ils ont la liberté de se faire
vacciner et qu' il ne faut pas au sens
où ce n'est pas une obligation mais
avant d ajouter je termine terminus est
pas en ayant le réel que vous allez le
changer lâchez vous dit que on ne risque
rien à cette date m'a dit ça je relève
je relaie ya pas dix ans je relève que
le principe de précaution qui a été
inscrit dans la constitution
il est celui de saint guy droit refait
mais bien celle du droit mais enfin
monsieur la ville régis de droit c'est
sûr c'est moi qui n'y est le réel qu'on
vous me dites corps ni très personnelle
sans dire où les banquiers je répondais
pas ça m'apprenait à moi qui ces
vaccinations accès vous dites tous les
pays du monde ont bondi en mai dans tous
les pays du monde et en israël m'avait
dit bien sûr je pense que ça c'est à
dessein c'est un détail se voit la 2de
ceci dit c'est dû faire des nuits du
gouvernement m division moi moi je suis
un peu choqué par tout ce que vous dites
vous êtes totalement irresponsable c'est
choquant il ya des millions de gens qui
attendent le vaccin va leur mettre le
doute dans la série c'est parce qu'il ya
des nazis d'émotion quand amis nous
allons te met en relation ça évoluer mon
cher m qu'est-ce qu'elle a évolué en
quoi bien encore la recherche là sur moi
est ce que vous croyez pas des autorités
je peux terminer les autorités
sanitaires européennes ont validé les
vaccins bernard sénéca aujourd'hui
pourquoi j'allais mettre ça en doute mes
rêves complot dit si j'ai posé parce que
j'ai répondu non vous votre avis donc
martin pour résumer c'est non pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de raison de
s'inquiéter
il est hors de question d'interdire le
vaccin stratégique et ça n'arrivera
jamais d'accord donc pour vous aucune
raison de s'alarmer du fait d'être
d'accord ferme et définitif mais marc
joueront des conteuses fabrici vous
rendez vous de ce que vous dites ça
n'arrivera jamais c'est un peu comme le
biais de ce qui n'est pas pénétrer en
france monsieur marché je crois que le
responsable c'est une question parce que
le virus
il ya un an il n'est pas arrivé sur le
territoire c'est ce même jamais dont
vous parlez vraiment c'est une question
ce que j'ai déjà dit
parce que monsieur ben la chine mais ça
m'intéresse parce que ce jamais toujours
ça mais sa main vous avez pas que les
prophètes depuis un an se sont tous
trompés
ça vous dit rien monsieur la chine et il
ya un truc qui me vient là comme ça une
question qui me vient à est-ce que vous
admettez l'hypothèse que peut-être
peut-être peut-être on découvre que au
fond il ya bien un lien entre le vaccin
et thrombose est ce que ça est ce que ça
vous paraît vous pensez de libye vous
pensez que je dis ça sans avoir réfléchi
non c'est une question donc ça nous
paraît impossible moi je des dizaines de
millions de personnes qu à vacciner que
s'est rien passé je bessieux de summer
dance à vous dites je pense aux
champions c'est sûr vous êtes sûr voilà
est donc aujourd'hui en tant que médecin
de santé publique où il vous dit aux
français
ne vous inquiétez pas le vaccin est
parfaitement sûr
alors je vais vous dire monsieur
blachier faites attention parce que je
vais vous dire pourquoi faites attention
vous avez une propension à oublier ce
que vous dites pas moi moi j'ai une
mémoire assez phénoménal trafic
effectivement je retiens précisément ce
que vous dites un problème monsieur
blachier j'aurais j'aurai l'honneur
l'immense honneur sur ce plateau de vous
le rappeler parce que je vous dise le
problème monsieur de lâcher c'est que
vous êtes un prétentieux présomptueux
vous n'avez que des hypothèses et
voulait transformer en scène sud
vous êtes d'une arrogance rare en venant
dire c'est sûr mais qui de vous pour
dire que c'est sûr ils réservent les
autorités ne vous explique qu'elle ya
une enquête pour savoir mais vous vous
avez déjà mené l enquête
pourquoi parce qu'il ya des millions de
gens et dont vous prenez ce taux était
danoise pour des imbéciles
mais quelle prévention sûrement chez
vous peut on attendait non seulement
c'est moi qui parle petit médecin de
santé publique
vous venez effectivement à la menace
[Musique]
jouer les indignés temps vous voulez
mais pardonnez moi un moment donné de
vous remettre à votre place monsieur
blaché vous n'êtes ni autorités
sanitaires et encore moins effectivement
autorités danoises voudrait pourquoi
danois quoi je vous parle pas vous
[Musique]
souhaite bien déjà beaucoup d'ennemis
versa les autorités soir vous n'avez ce
soir est dorénavant que mon pur mépris
[Rires]
je suis désolé de m'être gainey aurait
fait des primaires quand même vous
rappeler que le danemark vous explique
white vous expliqué xavier maman qu'une
enquête approfondie doit être menée là
exactement et ils disent par précaution
et là vous vous dites e10 par précaution
10 on doit mener enquête et on attend
les résultats de l'enquêté
quoique le lien de causalité soit
improbable mais non nécessaire à ce
stade pour suspendre et non un terrain
ça n'arrivera pas rappelez vous de ce
team à guillaume cieux
rappelez vous de ceux qui ont dit ça
n'arrivera pas dernier qu'ils ont dit
vous avez raison c'est le ministre de la
santé et un an plus tard nous sommes à
70 mille morts
j'entends mois pour une fois je suis
d'accord avec m des visages vous pour
une fois il est craint ce qu'il dit et
pour une fois il se positionne
il ya une différence entre suggéré aux
gens de se faire vacciner et forcer les
gens à se faire vacciner et par moments
à titre personnel conjointe ya des pays
qui suspendent la vaccination
et quand je vois qu'il ya des problèmes
avec ce vaccin c'est pas la première
folie même si on n'a pas beaucoup désolé
ça me fait flipper et j'ai pas envie de
me faire vacciner avec astrazeneca jradi
non m division je voudrais vous poser
une question si jamais dans quinze jours
le danemark deal et autorités de santé
danois disent ok alors il ya aucun lien
c'est bon on repart vous dites quoi
alesi jeudi très bien allez-vous faire
marie très bien
ok très bien c'est gilbert gress qui
veut s'adresser si vous avez perdu 30
pour je vais vous dire travail chez je
vais vous dire effectivement pourquoi
c'est intéressant parce que la question
en fait et pas très bien posé on dit
faute il argué reliera j'aurais dû
resserrer cette question car c'est moi
la question ne fallait pas interdire ces
contacts et surtout vendre ses on nous
dise quand il interdire est ce qu'on
peut
lacombe soulevé la question si je suis
en suspendre quand il est pour la
télésurveillance
d'ailleurs les états qui ont qui ont pas
interdit ils ont suspendu
moi si vous voulez je le redis sur ce
plateau je n'ai aucune difficulté avec
la vaccination est aussi à une sorte de
là il nous sort de là oui c'est bien
mais en même temps il faut aussi voulait
on a trop menti aux français durant un
an en leur présentant des hypothèses
comme des certitudes pour que moi je me
risque à le faire ce qu'ils veulent le
faire en prendre la responsabilité
mais moi je ne le ferais pas aller au
maximum au pardon je n'aime pas vous
faire vacciner
j'ai pas entendu parler vous n'allez pas
vous faire vacciner je n'ai pas besoin
d'amour je ne suis pas dans ce jeu vous
savez que je ne suis pas dans les
catégories qui peuvent si vous laissiez
s'abattre cependant j'ai 46 ans j'ai 46
ans est ce que vous savez montré l'étude
des autorités un cerveau grison est ce
que vous les présente que toi que je
réponds un élément intéressant vous
devriez est un petit peu près si vous
êtes plus jeune que castaldi mais
beaucoup plus jeune que gilles carez là
où c'est intéressant ce que vous êtes ce
que vous pouvez montrer les deux des
autorités danoises max aux divisions
j'entends une voix au loin mais je
dirais j'essaie de parler aux gens qui
gratte ça qu'on leur réponde je disais
si vous voulez je pense que quand on est
trop radical ou une interdiction
définitive ou la permission définitive
la question c'est qu'est-ce que je fais
quand j'ai un doute et c'est ça que
l'aco la cour de justice de l'union est
venu dégager l hemi de gager que dans le
doubs qui a dégagé un doute raisonnable
il s'agit de suspendre le temps
nécessaire et c'est ça en fait c'est pas
interdit que c'est ce double n'est pas
raisonnable là mais vous pouvez passer
une pas raisonnable et sage et vous
n'êtes pas juge de sa monsieur de la
chine je dois donner moi mais c'est bien
sur quoi votre avis il se fonde sur le
nombre de personnes vaccinées
ah ouais quand même enfin la programmer
moi je suis arrivé j'ai un élément qui a
peut-être vous donner raison
c'était sur le râteau tpm p vous croyez
en la voyance voyance non connaissez
claude alexis non on connaissait claude
alexis regardez regardez le liban comme
sa venue et axel pour moi ce vaccin ne
sera pas
un peu les quatre très efficace en est
je dirais que pourrait vraiment un
vaccin qui puisse appeler 15 émerger
pour ans minimum et non je dirais entre
18 et 24 mois
et y'en as qui est sur le marché à
l'heure actuelle de mc5 été où il ya une
autorisation mais qui sera retiré
d'accord alors je voudrais si vous me
permettez justement quand même une
phrase qui devrait vous avait rasé sa
sur un arrêt commission contre français
les 10 à 15 ans fin août est quelque
chose de très demi que l'état peut en
vertu du principe de précaution prendre
des mesures de protection sans avoir à
attendre que la réalité et la gravité
des risques soient pleinement démontrée
c'est sous lui on n'a pas de lui
construire la panique ça ne s'appelait
pas le contraire fabrice s'applique pas
dans le principe son application sur le
vaccin
monsieur blachier c'est qu'encore une
fois vous employer des mots dont vous ne
me comprenait riez vous études qui sont
bidons donc montré moins à l'étude the
ground and oil et en anglais c'est là
qu'on voit la photo
quelle est la faute aux danois les
photos ça fait 12 6 et montrez moi c'est
une fois j'ai la question juste
accessoires photo copenhague
oui vous le savez qu'il est ridicule ou
pas derrière ça il ya vous connaissez
mieux que moi c'est une posture qui se
développe entre elle et une posture il
est ridicule parce qu il fait le clown
oui c'est bien voilà il amusé
téléspectateurs quelques-uns si vous
voulez que toujours un imbécile dans une
dans une ordure l'avant toujours
influent bourrin donc c'est lui c'est
tombé sur lui c'est bien mais maintenant
la question
il est tout le temps comme ça vous
pensez vous fabrice di vizio en plus
mais je suis d'accord avec lui mais le
problème c'est que heavy rain quand la
gamme d'études vous défoncer la mettez
des certitudes c'est vous monsieur marc
dont la seule certitude est que j'ai je
vous donne ma maison
avec vous nous pipeauté mason parce que
même si vous avez raison vous venez avec
des choses et des masques à chaque fois
vous dites que je suis ridicule
moi j'ai l'honneur parfois de dire je ne
sais pas mais vous avez de faux études
vous brandissez un truc avec une photo
bidon montré moins l'étude d'allouagne
d'ailleurs on se calme montre là mon
équipe n'a pas déçu parce que rien n'a
de droit voilà exactement une étude n'y
a pas d'étude dollars
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose de sérieux sur plusieurs
mois ou pas non juste n'y a pas d'étude
est ce que je suis dans marque on attend
d'étudier et d'un arbre dans le doute
comme il ya une relation de coïncidence
je m'abstiens ça s'appelle le principe
de précaution c'est d'accord d'accord
alors juste une question c'est bien en
fait s'il ya plusieurs personnes qui ont
quand même eu des thromboses malgré
qu'elles se soient fait vacciner ça veut
bien dire qu'il n'y a pas de coïncidence
donc même si le pourcentage est tout
minimes
il faudrait pouvoir le marqué par
exemple dans la notice dire ok il ya un
pourcentage de temps et ans après qu'est
ce qui est pire se faire vacciner et
risquer la thrombose ou avoir le
coronavirus on a combien de pourcentage
de chance quand on l'a de mourir aussi
je veux dire ou alors on est quatre
combien juste martin blachier juste pour
savoir est ce que les seuls effets
secondaires ce sont toujours les mêmes
donc des thromboses ou pas ou est ce
qu'il ya d'autres effets secondaires ou
est ce qu on a vu qu'à chaque fois
qu'ils avaient le vaccin astrazeneca
il y avait des risques de trombes d'eau
sur plusieurs patients pour l'instant le
seul car un peu grave c'est cette
thrombose
mais sa carrière qui sont sortis
récemment sur des millions de personnes
quelques thromboses et des thromboses y
en a des milliers tous les ans c'est
quelque chose de très banal la thrombose
des primes au surnom des gens de votre
famille qu'ont déjà une taxe qu'on était
anti qu est-ce que c'est grave et ça
s'est très bien passé de la plupart du
temps c'est pas grave du tout corps de
temps en temps ça peut être est ce qu'on
essaie ça vient des vaccins n'est pas
fumer mais c'est ça on n'était pas sûr
non plus que le virus allait arriver en
france
et pourtant aujourd'hui on a trois
ministres poursuivis devant la cour de
justice c'est jeu c'est un l'occurrence
et je sens une abstention volontaire de
combattre un sinistre
parce qu'on a dit dans le doute nous
auriez quand même les abrets jamais
opposé à tous les les séries dans tous
les pays
personne ne sait jamais mais quand vous
écoutez les médecins à force de
déprogrammer des urgences vous savez des
cancers il faut un bar sert à
s'embarquer sur ce cours elle détecte et
y inclure de trucs donc on va dire aussi
qu'il ya des gens qui se sont fait une
sérieuse menée qui sont morts d'un camp
il faut plein de s'embarquer sur plus de
déprogrammation alors la déprogrammation
monsieur lé habituel
je suis désolé monsieur reprenez les
chiffres chaque année monsieur blackman
forcé à menacer les bleus pas d'accord
d'accord là dessus c'est le château vous
avez les transferts et les
déprogrammations aussi monsieur blachier
reprenez flochon reprenez les plans
effectivement pandémie grippale de 2018
ça s'est déroulé en 2014
en 2010 huit mètres division dossiers
des villes danoises juste mettre plein
la vue aux bandits c'est le principe de
précaution pour veut l'entendre pourquoi
pas mais alors quand on peaufine les
gens c'est pas des précautions quand on
quand on recommande aux grottes de
porter un masque pas la précaution assez
du masque si bien sûr d'accord donc en
fait appel aux sens et quand ça vous
arrange
non abbassi massy abassi mais pas devant
le dos de la bassine et des mois de
pause est sous le coup des
démonstrations étaient assis à ma place
et dramatique de danse à eux de faire la
preuve
non vous l'avez vous l'avez pas dit ça
deviendra match nul à chier vous êtes
juste dramatique pourra pourquoi
pourquoi le confinement c'est vous qui
n'avez pas été en mesure de me donner la
moindre étude prouvant son
fonctionnement vous m'avez émotions
opposées des chiffres là où les pays
confiné nous confiner s'en sortent de la
même façon vous avez trois études
successives qui vous disent que ça
marche pas même le conseil scientifique
dans la lettre aux lancers est revient
dessus alors s'il vous plaît essayez de
pas un dieu a été spectateur en erreur
en racontant n'importe quoi ça fait
plaisir à tout le monde
varta blachier est ce que on va s'en
sortir ou pas oui on va s'en sortir et
très bientôt dès qu'on aura suffisamment
de doses de vaccins et qu'on arrêtera
d'écouter les gens qui disent qu'il faut
presque faire vacciner mais de toute
façon ce sera très vite oublié parce que
c'est la seule porte de douai elle
arrive très loin cette info qui vient de
tomber juste fabriquer vidéo la facture
des patients traités à l'hypoxie
chloroquine à liège chu de marseille
s'est sorti dans capital un journal très
sérieux une simple consultation dans
l'établissement du professeur raoult a
été facturé 1264 bureau aux malades du
colis de 19 alors je vais vous dire
c'est notoirement impossible à lotois
moins possible l'impossible kg comment
ça c'est capital pour conserver au
capital vous savez pourquoi c'est
impossible
pourquoi parce qu'on a affaire à des
praticiens hospitaliers qui n'ont pas de
consultation libérale bien sûr paradis à
je suis embêté si il ya des il ya des
consultations privées non non non non
non non vous voyez battant des ailes
quand à vous n'allez pas me dire si je
suis sûr de ça jure c'est mon boulot de
la journée vous avez lourd acteurs vous
avez quoi contre l'hôpital c'est mon
boulot de la journée que la sat avocat
ben oui ajouté dans un hôpital je suis
avocat des hôpitaux et des méthodes
c'est à dire en l'occurrence c'est le
principe de la consultation publique et
ensuite vous avez la consultation
libérale du praticien et là en
l'occurrence il s'agit de consultation
publique
et si les 1200 euros ont été facturés
c'est probablement parce qu'ils
correspondent à une série d'examens
nomenclature et un ecg que c'est j'en
sais rien et donc ils sont facturés au
tarif de l'assurance maladie
voilà quant au reste effectivement j'ai
pas l'habitude de commenter des études
de capital si elle bat autant que les
avis sur le plateau
capoue taxi question non je vous écoute
moi j'étais plutôt je comprends ce
principe de précaution mais je pense
qu'on n'a pas le choix aujourd'hui que
de se vacciner malgré tout et que je
pense que ces gens auraient pu avoir la
thrombose quoi qu'il advienne comme l'a
dit le docteur il en savait gamme non
mais sauf que mais sauf qu'il ya plein
thrombose tout le temps et en fait voilà
tout c'est le bénéfice risque et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui vaut mieux se
vacciner c'est la seule solution par le
droit d'user droit de le penser dans les
autorités danoises ne le pense pas les
autorités dans les environs vient en
effet de tous les autres pays d' un
peut-être mais certaines vous savez
monsieur blachier alors je vais vous
donner la raison tient pour le truc
la raison pour chaque patient léa chu de
marseille à facturer une hospitalisation
de jour
ce que je vous disais on nous parle
maintenant de spécialisation de jours
mais en fait la prise en charge dure 10
minutes pour faire les prises de sons 3
minutes 30 pour faire l'électro me colle
électrocardiogramme et cinq minutes la
consultation pour la délivrance de
l'hydroxyte leur équipe et voilà le
reste ce n'est que de la tente dans les
couloirs et donc montant de la facture
totale 3800 euros
et là qu'est ce qu'il vous dise jeudi on
a ouvert 3 on va toujours se redire la
même chose c'est-à-dire que si vous avez
des éléments à ce sujet je suis preneur
et jean débat si vous avez un article
qui vous dit on a dit que j'en ai pas
pas c'est tout bon non mais c'est on
arrange pas c'est toujours des barges
compenser les téléspectateurs qu'ils
soient sans tuer pour cent faut-il
suspendre le vaccin c'est l'ancienne et
karoui 68% au pouvoir que les gens ont
peur à leurs oeufs ça c'est dur c'est
cette réponse à bas falloir ramer pour
amener les gens vers la vaccination
on va le faire les gens se diront
sélectionné quoi qu'il arrive les
ramener dans l'axé nation oui c'est ça
voilà exhaler rama oui oui je remercie
mon bras mais bien